in this era of high throughput
sequencing
the importance of genomic or cdna
libraries
are kind of diminished but back in 1970s
screening cdna libraries or screening
genomic dna libraries was crucial for
the scientists to know more about the
genome
or the transcriptome now that is why
let's talk about the screening
strategies that they used to use
for knowing that a particular cdna of
interest
or a gene of interest is present in a
library or not
and one of the technique that they use
is called colony hybridization
so let's see how it is done so let's say
we have taken a cell and under certain
circumstances we wanted to know about
the expression libraries
so we need to dissociate the cell break
the cell membrane
take out the rna make cdna of it and
then clone this cdna in specific vectors
now we have a collection of vectors we
would transfect these vectors
into e coli and in a plate we would have
thousands of colonies each harboring a
specific
sequence of interest now it's a
probability event
we don't know which colony correspond to
which of these
gene of interest now our goal is to
identify
this particular gene whether it is
present in these
call in the among this colony or not and
in order to do that
we can use a technique known as colony
hybridization
so let me introduce you to that
technique so first of all we have to do
a replica plating
that means we have to have two plates
with exact equal architecture of the
colonies
now after that replica plating we put a
nitrocellulose membrane
and on this nitrocellulose membrane some
imprint of these
colonies would be there and
note that there is a marker which would
help you to understand
in which orientation you have trace
these colonies from the plate
now in this nitrocellulose membrane we
can fix this
nitrocellulose membrane and add a
reagent which would
denature the cellular components and
expose the dna or cdn
expose the dna or cdnas now
after that we need to identify this cdna
sequence or dna sequence whether it is
present or not
in order to use do that we would use
radio level probes
or any kind of labeled probes after
putting the
radio level probes
the sequence of interest if it is
present then we would see it would
hybridize with these radio level probes
if it is not present then it won't
hybridize with the probes
and the probe would not show any signal
so after washing these nitrocellulose
membrane
if you develop it then you would see
at a specific region you would see a
spot later on tracking that particular
spot
to a corresponding replica plate you
would know the location of the colony
which is harboring your gene of interest
or your cdna of interest
then we can isolate that colony and
expand that colony for our further
future usage
so this is all about colony
hybridization
fairly simple to understand but this
process was very important in 1970s or
1980s
but honestly these days nobody used this
technique that much
but anyway we learned about colony
hybridization in this short video so i
hope you enjoyed this video if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
you can support me in patreon and you
can access my course in an academy
using my code mp10 you would get a 10
discount thank you guys